and tonight biden jets abroad for the
first middle east trip of his presidency
and yes it is filled with the typical
blunders we'll show you the low light
straight ahead also tonight piers morgan
he will join us to discuss his calls
that america should invoke the 25th
amendment to remove joe biden that's
coming up but first tonight we start
right here at home where biden's failed
far left climate calls to cultists
extremist socialist agenda it is costing
you the american people more and more
and more as a matter of fact more than
ever before because believe it or not
shouldn't shock you biden's inflation
hit yet another
40-year high today
even above projections the highest
number to date under biden
a new high record at a dismal 9.1
percent remember it was only 1.4 percent
when he took office this puts biden's
white house failures in full view as
this extremely destructive democratic
agenda is hitting americans everywhere
from the gas pump to the grocery aisle
and everywhere in between take a look at
your screen this is what you're paying
just year over year gas is up 60 percent
it's doubled since he's become president
now chicken up another 18 eggs up 33
food costs across the board new new cars
used cars they're all up airfare yep
cost a lot more for jet fuel that's up
34
pretty much everything you pay for is
costing you a lot more and it's all
because of the economic and energy
reckless policies of joe biden and of
course the climate alarmist green new
deal agenda according to the new data
the average worker has lost
three thousand four hundred dollars in
annual income as a result of joe's
inflation and for families it is a
whopping six thousand eight hundred
dollars annually that's a new tax now
remember it was joe biden who said back
in december inflation had peaked another
complete lie now add all of that yet to
another warning sign that's gone largely
unnoticed car repossessions yeah they're
exploding right now what barons is
calling quote uh an underappreciated
ticking time bomb is this yet another
bubble that's about to burst and even
the mob in the media including those of
fake news cnn they're saying there's no
silver lining to these inflation numbers
and there's not take a look
it was an ugly report very hard to find
any silver linings here and even though
this expectation and even though this
report was higher than expectations it
is perhaps no surprise to americans who
know and have been feeling inflation is
painfully high right now
but overall it still is 9.1 and it
it's a bad number any way you look at it
when i look at this report i don't see
any relief anywhere we even before we
got to this 9.1 percent there had been
some sectors that were behaving a little
bit better i look at rents going up i
didn't see any relief in apparel there
was some hope
folks that maybe with the inventory that
courtney reagan's been talking about at
some of the department stores that you
might see some relief in apparel not
much there
so tonight we'll be honest as honest as
we can be with you they keep talking
about a soft landing i don't see any
soft landing here there are no solutions
coming from joe biden in fact what we're
getting is the exact opposite because
yet again today biden played another
blame game releasing a statement quote
it's a it's a reminder that all major
economies are battling this
covet-related challenge made worse by
putin's unconscionable aggression gas
prices grocery prices they were all
surging well before putin's invasion we
have shown you this chart over and over
again joe biden artificially reduced the
supply of the world's energy before
putin's invasion joe biden killed the
keystone xl pipeline put all these
restrictions on domestic energy
production long before putin's invasion
biden and the democrats they ran through
the coveted relief package that wasn't
actually for covert before putin's
invasion it has been one lie after
another lie after another lie now these
far left failures they overheated the
economy they spent way too much money
and now they want to blame everyone but
themselves first they blame the pandemic
then they blame vladimir putin then they
blame rich people and they blame big oil
then they blame gas station owners then
they blame republicans then you can
always blame donald trump when
all else fails and even fox news but now
at least one democrat is taking things a
step further and is actually blaming the
summer heat for joe biden's struggles
guess it's too hot out there you know
too hot
for what joe to polwell is that what it
is take a look
president biden's poll numbers are
sinking a new york times siena college
poll found 64 percent of registered
voters if voting in the democratic
primary would prefer someone other than
joe biden as the democratic nominee in
2024. um what's your reaction to that so
i really look at those numbers yes as
dissatisfaction as the frustration of
the summer the heat
but i'm ready for the fall when we
really turn that election around after
labor day
all right don't forget what this all
means it means that if you're seeing a
modest wage increase that wage increase
is totally completely wiped out by biden
inflation and then some and even if
you're earning more your purchasing
power is less and less and less joe
biden is now the pay cut president where
you pay more you earn less and while the
standard of living for everyday
americans is taking one hit after
another regardless of what the white
house tries to spin you there's no
mystery here biden made it clear during
the campaign that this is what he wanted
to do this is what a far left climate
warrior does he said over and over again
he had to pay attention he would
eliminate fossil fuels in america at
least domestic production he wanted to
decrease american energy independence
had no problem meaning if you paid more
at the pump and biden and the climate
cult and the democrats they've made it
clear they have no problem compromising
u.s energy security no problem crippling
the economy they will do virtually
nothing to increase the world's supply
of energy we have hundreds of years
worth of domestic energy available to us
it's under our feet you don't have to
beg texas joe to pump more oil biden is
giving up the greatest opportunity we
have to lower inflation reduce prices
create high paying career jobs give us
national security every item every store
that we shop at we can reduce delivery
costs significantly that will be passed
on to we the people the consumers but he
has to cling to his democratic
party's climate cult
it is dangerous it's delusional and most
of all it's simply destructive to the
health and welfare of every hard-working
american across this country two-thirds
of americans now they're living paycheck
to paycheck joe can the president of the
united states for once think for himself
at all is that even possible can he
actually stand up to the far left
radical extremists that are running the
country on his behalf likely not
considering you know we're not even sure
if he knows that today is wednesday hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else